I grew up in a studio apartment the size
of this office at the age that my son is
now I view that I have the advantage
over him most people don't
[Music]
I got very lucky I grew up in a
situation where I was losing from day
one we were humble immigrants I got
picked on for not speaking English I
wasn't a good student
I wasn't been excelling athlete which
allowed me to create an enormous amount
of thick skin to doing things and not
being scared of judgement because I was
being judged from the beginning
do you know how noxious li thick my skin
is when it comes to business I give a
[ __ ] what anybody says about me or
thinks of me or thinks what I'm doing
I'm willing to go work picking up
garbage right now right now it just
doesn't seem so crazy to me people get
[ __ ] fancy I'm still doing the [ __ ]
that got me here even though people
think I got somewhere you may think I
got somewhere I don't think I'm
somewhere I'm still in the same [ __ ]
process and I'm never gonna forget what
I'm about and I like getting my hands
dirty now answer that email and I'll
stop and have that conversation and I'll
take that pitch and I do unscalable not
the right use of my time [ __ ] 50% of my
day every day for the rest of my life
because I love the [ __ ] dirt
I love the grind I'll never get fancy
I don't like fancy and so that's
important to me I think everybody all
those bosses I took to walk the way I
was picked on heavily kids forced me to
drink pee out of a Pepsi can I was 4
foot 11 my freshman year of high school
not good no short I could you know my
home my infrastructure the pain and the
punishment that that neighborhood put on
me as a little [ __ ] that couldn't
speak English
I thank you don't worry and I remind all
of you all your shortcomings and losses
and negativity is yesterday it is all
fundamentally behind you even the worst
of it and it is up to you to step
forward and start positive offense as
your new truth and I beg that for you
and I hope this [ __ ] project
suffocated
and inspired it and created it and
enabled it
and they looked
you